the next Democratic primary is once
again a caucus it is in Nevada in fact
on February 22nd and I wish I had better
news but sadly it does look like the
Nevada Democratic caucus is going to be
another embarrassingly convoluted mess
kind of building on the mess of the Iowa
caucus on February 3rd the big news
after Iowa and the complete failure of
the app that Iowa's was using to
communicate the results from different
parts of the state Nevada
decided they are not going to use the
same app that imploded in Iowa they had
initially planned to use that app
they're changing their plans and this
made a lot of people think it's
definitely going to go more smoothly in
Nevada than it did in Iowa and in some
ways it still might but there are more
and more reasons to be concerned about
what's going to happen in Nevada one
issue is okay well they're abandoning
the app that didn't work well in Iowa
but what are they replacing it with
you've got to replace it with something
there is not a super clear answer right
now according to the Associated Press
Nevada Democrats told precinct leaders
you will be getting an iPad the day of
the caucuses Seth Morrison is a site
leader who's going to oversee a bunch of
different precincts in the Las Vegas
area and Seth said he was told he would
be trained on the iPad when he picks it
up a few days before the caucuses and
then on the day of the caucuses he will
have to teach the precinct leaders how
to use these iPads that they're going to
be getting that doesn't sound great to
me I don't know about you but that's not
sounding that's not inspiring huge
levels of confidence number two in
Nevada they will be reporting three sets
of numbers for the first time similar to
in Iowa there's going to be the initial
vote totals from the first sort of round
then there's the realignment based on
candidates that don't meet the 15%
viability threshold have to realign to
other candidates and then you have a
final vote total and then you have to
report the final delegate number these
all of these steps at opportunities for
human error and chaos and confusion and
we've talked about more generally what
about getting rid of the caucus system
altogether but then the REE
factor is that Nevada on top of all of
the caucus craziness has early voting
which Iowa did not have now you might be
thinking to yourself well in a primary
you just send in who you're voting for
early that's no big deal it gets counted
on the day of the election how on earth
do you do early voting in a caucus and
the way it works interestingly enough is
early voters who want to participate in
the caucus have to use a ranked choice
valid ballot since you won't be there to
see whether your top choice meets the
15% viability threshold and if they
don't you get realigned to some other
candidate you have to in advance
order the candidates in terms of
preferences so this is another element
that could wreak just absolute and total
havoc at the local precinct level in
Nevada when tallying up the votes
because it all has to be done during
that few hour period that the caucus is
taking place and then on top of this to
add just like an almost cartoonish
element to everything instead of you
know in Iowa they would do the coin
flips for tie breakers Nevada and it
sort of is fitting because of Las Vegas
Nevada is going to do a card game there
will be a high card draw you draw a card
and whoever gets the high card that
candidate gets the tiebreak the which is
just absolutely crazy any system that
involves coin flips or drawing cards to
decide who wins even at the at the micro
delegate level it's a bad system the one
simplifying element in Nevada is that
there are only delegates there aren't
delegates and state delegate equivalents
like in Iowa that's a good thing so
growing concern from Nevada Democrats
should be concerned given what we are
learning there Nevada has 36 delegates
up for grabs this makes it roughly the
size of Iowa Iowa had 41 delegates New
Hampshire had 24 delegates and then on
top of everything as as as we as of
right now we don't really have good
recent polling from Nevada the latest
poll is from January 11 that makes it
difficult to even have some kind of a
base number to compare vote totals to
which can help to sniff out problems if
you have a bunch of recent polls and a
candidate is polling 10 and then they
get 40 then that raises a red flag and
you've got to figure out whether those
results are accurate
hopefully by February 22nd which is the
day of the Nevada caucuses there will be
more more recent polling one other kind
of messy thing in Nevada which is even
more acute than in Iowa in Iowa where
you vote vote sort of matters and as we
saw Pete Buda jej got the largest number
of Delegates despite not getting the
largest number of votes in Nevada this
is even more pronounced
Nevada's total population is just a hair
over three million people Las Vegas has
about 20% of that population 650,000
Reno has another 250,000 so between Las
Vegas and Reno you have about 30% of the
total population of the state in just
those two cities because of that
urban-rural divide in Nevada you can win
big in urban centers and lose on
delegates and you can have all of these
wacky scenarios so if you look at 2008
for example in 2008 in the Nevada caucus
Barack Obama came away with 13 delegates
and Hillary got 12 but Obama lost the
popular vote totals by about 6
percentage points still got more
delegates than Hillary this is more
pronounced than it was in Iowa this year
in 2016 there was also a pretty
unbalanced delegate total relative to
the popular vote in 2016 Hillary won the
popular vote by just 5 percentage points
but she got 57% of the delegates a much
larger share and of course this in part
is because of those viability thresholds
that we talked about earlier today in
any caucus this can happen in Nevada
that urban-rural divide can make it even
even more acute so let's hope for the
best
ideally they're preparing for the worst
the silver lining here is that and this
is a weird silver lining it's another
very small number of delegates on Super
Tuesday March 3rd all of these primaries
it's off first of all it's all primaries
from from what I recall and it is a much
larger number of Delegates a lot of
potentially difference making
I'm Aries on March 3rd so if there's any
silver lining about Nevada it's that
it's not that many delegates and if it
gets royally screwed up it's unlikely to
drastically affect the total delegate
counts I know that that's extremely it's
an extremely low bar to be setting but
it is what it is almost all American
journalism is controlled by a few
massive corporations and news voice is a
one of a kind mobile app that tracks the
bias and corporate interests that infuse
the news stories we consume every day
and it's totally free to use it's a
great tool to have on your phone news
voice is not funded by advertisers or
corporate investors the platform is
supported by contributions from users
like you the news voice app will have
some really excellent new features soon
specifically for the 2020 election but
they're wanting to expand their team of
independent journalists in order to keep
everything running they're offering
special rewards to anyone who wants to
give to their new Kickstarter campaign
which can be found at news voice dot-com
/ kik giving a contribution will come
with rewards like insider access to
group chats with news voice staff
members as well as access to a variety
of special features go see what news
voice is all about